Walt Disney's a nice man,
but Bambi was not a good thing for our,
our collective psyche around hunting,
not just Bambi,
but essentially all cartoons involving
animals to animals. Where your friends,
yes. Even predators, like Yogi was
your friend. He was your friend.
He wore a tie is a bear attack.
Um, and he had a hat on. Yeah,
he was at a picnic basket and wanted your
picnic. Jamie. Look up, there was a guy,
there was a dude,
um,
recently he was caught poaching and
Missouri and the judge said that he had to
um, watch Bambi once a month
during his entire sentence.
Why? It's if you find that that is real,
that just needs a reality show. He like,
oh, I don't know what to do, honey. I
know what to do. We'll make it much Bambi.
He poached a deer.
This is the guy who like the whole other,
it was like a whole family
guys. Here we're in like a
poaching ring or something.
I read this on the way
over here. Um, here it is.
Dear poacher sentence to watch Bambi every
month during a year in Missouri jail.
Yeah. This might be a judge that's
like looking for a little steely,
killed hundreds of deer sometimes taking
over their heads and leaving the rest
to Rodan fields. Keep. Ah,
how about you keep that guy in jail
for more than a year? There he is.
Look at him. David Barry Jr. Look at him.
Fucking Dork has been ordered
to watch one thing, man.
If that guy was killing him because he
was poor and he was just eating deer and
that's how he made his, that's how he got
food. That's not the case. He don't care.
He chopping the heads off and just
took the heads guy. Just fuck.
Fuck anybody who does that anyway.
Fuck anybody who just wants to shoot
something as damn delicious and massive as
a deer. A deer could feed a family
for months. Do you understand?
Of course it could.
You understand that,
but I mean people
listening or this asshole,
do you understand that this asshole who
shot this fucking thing a hundred years
head off you piece of shit
five I'm puncher can look
forward to eating deer and
you shot it and you, yeah. Anyway,
back back like Walt Disney.
I think like that kind of
treatment of animals has been,
it's been something that's hurt honey.
And the third one is hunters.
I've heard themselves like that guy.
Like maybe that's a poacher.
Not a nice way worse. That's a
poacher. Not a hunter though.
But he's a guy who hunting
illegally. That's what it
poaching is. He's honor. Yeah,
but like camping. Camping illegally. He's
trespassing. It's not the same. Yeah,
but you're camping. You're trespassing
in camping. Camping. Right. Maybe he's,
I know you don't want them to call him a
hunter. Like you know, like someone who,
who goes on stage at a company
picnic is not a comedian. Yes.
It's the same thing. I get it. Yeah. I
mean he's still killing animals. Yeah.
He's killing more than me.
That's a hundred. Yeah.
I'm a hunter and he's killed more
than the official budget. That's true.
This is a piece of shit he is, but
that's just like everything else, man.
There's people that are good Uber drivers
and there's some that will try to pull
you under a bridge and fuck your mouth.
This is bad people.
That's a good point to bring up.
Like is there,
is there a time like I always bring
up with hunting, it's, it's like, oh,
somebody killed a giraffe or somebody,
the guy killed a family,
baboons and made a and did a photo. I
saw that. Do you see that? Not Good.
Not Good. Well that's, that's
a fucking primate bro. Yeah.
I mean there's nothing good about that
with the idea that we're going to go well
for you. It's never going to go well
for you. Yeah. Did he put it online? No,
he didn't put her on line is I guess the,
the credit that we would give
the guy who put it online,
the Idaho Statesman or whatever the
Idaho local paper was a picture,
I don't know, per from one of
the folks, he sent an email,
a mass email out to some friends and
colleagues and things of like recapping,
recapping is hunt in Africa. Like
here's all the things I did. And He,
I think from my reading when the guy
shot the guy and I got a lot of mutual
friends with him, so he's a good
guy. Like he just screwed up. I made,
made a bad choice. That's a
tough sell, I would say so too.
But I should put him in a cell and make,
he is a monkey movies.
I think he knew like if I put this,
if I put this, you got to watch,
that's going to spin up after this
planet of the apes.
You gotta watch the Mark Wahlberg Planet
of the apes, the reality of baboons.
And I have, um, I've studied
the work of Robert Sapolsky,
who's a guy who's been on
the podcast before in it's,
it's really pretty amazing stuff.
What they found out about baboons that
he studied actually because he actually
studied a baboons tribe that
the Alpha males died off.
They were all eating out of
a poisoned garbage patch. Uh,
there was a garbage patch to that sick
food in it. And um, uh, just bad food.
And the Alpha males who got to eat first
always chased everybody that they wound
up dying off.
And for more than one generation,
I think it was several generations,
they became like really peaceful and
calm and they weren't the vicious violent
baboons that are the norm. And that it's
true. It's really, if you Google it, uh,
so Paul Ski Studies, baboons and I and
radio lab also had a podcast about it,
which is where I first heard about it.
And then I read what
supple ski wrote about it.
But it is unbelievably fascinating.
It shows how you can have this
insane violent animal culture.
And then the,
the Kuntz get removed.
And when the cons get removed, everybody
chills the fuck out. And it's really,
really quite fascinating. But I'm
baboons for the most part. I mean,
maybe he shot the nicest Pelicans ever,
but for the most part,
they're a bunch of baby and cunts
and they'll steal your fucking kid.
That little two year old
that you love so dearly,
that little motherfucker be
on a, uh, a porch somewhere.
And if there's baboons around,
they'll snatch him and hit his head.
That's like when I was in Africa,
I hunted Africa one time in my life and
the R P H and r guide both said at our
church as a professional honor,
right?
The structure is like there's
a professional hunter,
which is essentially your guide.
And then there's trackers
which are usually native
folks that that help tracking
the game, spot, the animals, things
like that. But our, our Ph, he was like,
if you see a bad Boone shoot it.
It's like we have Eri,
we have lots of irrigation here to
maintain this ranch and they rip it up and
they're, you know, basically
terrorists around, you know,
coming around at our camp,
mess with their fires,
messing our food was it,
you see one shoot one and that was the
instruction that I got and I never,
never did. But you know,
given that instruction from
somebody like that, like, hey,
this is a good thing for our landscape.
Go and do it now.
That's very far removed
from stacking them up,
like stack very far and with a big
smile on your face holding a bow isn't,
it doesn't make any sheen a baby. There's
some babies. It's like a whole family.
You can't, they don't stay in one place
either. You guys came to you and I said,
listen Joe,
here's my plan.
What I'm going to do is go to
Africa and hunt and then you know,
like I'm going to shoot some baboons.
I mean it's a good thing for this.
I'd be like, don't tell anybody. Yeah.
You'd be like, don't, don't take,
certainly don't take a photo of you posing
with an entire family of the deceased
primate. I had a friend who was in
Africa and he got attacked by, by boom,
boom bap, boom to steals
food. Yeah. I forgot what the
context of it was. It was, uh,
quite a few years ago,
but he said it was spooky.
He said they don't seem like a a monkey
and they don't seem like they seem like
a dog monkey.
Like could you ever see when
they open their mouth? Yes.
It's like a dog mouth.
They're like dog monkey.
It's like a dog fucked a monkey.
Like if you really like show a baboons,
baboons with its mouth open.
Never thought of it that way.
But I'll give it to you,
but they have a long stretched out mouth,
like a wolf or something that's
not, it's like a werewolf. Yeah.
It's not like a regular person.
They're real weird man. They, they,
they have all these characteristics
that are of primates,
but then they have this extra
weirdness to them as well. Yeah.
And this wildness to him too,
but it doesn't that come down to like
the core of some of these. Oh my God.
I mean, come on, look at that. That's
like a werewolf. Yeah. That is a werewolf.
That's like part, look
at that face, that lion.
I can roll back, but look at
this. Even the shape of the jaw.
It's very dog.
Like it's very elongated and dog.
Like they're very, it's a very
strange animal. Look at that face man.
And that is a crazy beast.
And my friend said, uh,
I forget the story is
quite a long time ago,
I stole some food and snarled at him and,
and snatch something from him.
But he said it was very scary. He said,
and you know, it wasn't even that big,
would be like 60 70 pounds or
something like that. And he said,
but it's been pending.
They'll fuck you up.